un match spectaculaire le choc de cette
14e journée d'excellence entre maurepas
et l'équipe réserve de versailles a tenu
toutes ses promesses
mené deux fois au score les verts de
mort pas réussi à s'accrocher pour
égaliser deux fois grâce à un doublé de
leur ailier christopher maréchal
ça fait du bien en plus cette année je
me suis souvent blessé donc là c'est mon
deuxième match seulement avec l'asm en
excellence et je pense continuer sur
cette lancée
pourquoi pas marquer tous les dimanches
en fin de rencontre la partie aurait pu
basculer du côté des morts passe bien
mais l'arbitré décidé de refuser la
réalisation de l'intenable maréchal
suite à une faute sur le gardien
le troisième but je n'ai pas vu parce
que je les célèbres avant de marquer
donc du coup je me suis un peu
déconcentré et les défenseurs est revenu
malheureusement suite j'ai fait faute et
invite à siphonner le score n'évoluera
plus les deux équipes restent dos à dos
2 buts partout
on avait la volonté de gagner ce match
là pour continuer un petit peu notre
notre marche en avant mais vu la
physionomie du match je suis plus que
satisfait des deux points parce que je
pense que mon repas méritait de gagner
aujourd'hui aurait mérité de gagner
parce que il était plus d'argent parce
que y
ils ont mieux joué que nous on les a
empêchés de jouer et le 2 2 on est un
peu déçu du résultat car on méritait de
gagner
au classement ce match nul arrange les
deux équipes maurepas conserve sa
quatrième place face à son poursuivant
le pecq
de son côté l'équipe 2 de versailles
reste leader d'excellence avec deux
matches de retard
c'est important de ne pas perdre en même
si avec des matches nuls on n'avance pas
beaucoup je connais pas les autres
résultats limite je mange mange m'en
fiche de ce soir on a fait un retour à
la compétition qu'on a géré moyennement
on va dire et voilà maintenant on va
bien se préparer pour aller gagner en
mai prochain
ce dimanche 5 mars versailles se rendra
sur le terrain de guyancourt
saint-quentin l'équipe senior de
maurepas se déplacera quant à elle sur
le terrain d'aubergenville